y precisamente para hablar de este tema
saludamos en la capital canadiense a
Salvador herencia Carrasco les abogado y
docente de la Universidad de Ottawa ha
trabajado como asesor jurídico de la
comisión andina de juristas asesor
jurisdiccional senior del tribunal
constitucional de Perú y asesor jurídico
del Ministerio de Justicia y Derechos
Humanos de Perú Bienvenido a otras 24
Salvador hay una ruptura del orden
democrático en Perú según lo establecido
en la carta Interamericana
No necesariamente la carta democrática
Interamericana tiene una serie de
situaciones para ayudar a mantener y
preservar el institucionalidad
democrática lo que ha hecho el gobierno
peruano en estos en estos días ha sido
solicitar una una audiencia por parte
del Consejo permanente frente a lo que
se considera son ciertas actuaciones por
parte del Congreso y otras autoridades
que podrían menoscabar la
institucionalidad democrática de acuerdo
a los artículos 17 y 18 la carta ahora
esta carta habla de un principio de no
intervención pero señala que podría
solicitar asistencia para preservar la
democracia Qué acciones Se podrían tomar
en este caso la reuniones de los
consejos permanentes de la oea podrían
ordenar visitas podrían ordenar informes
pero a su vez lo más importante es una
labor de mediación y hay que tener en
cuenta que en la historia del Perú la
oea jugó un papel muy importante la
transición democrática entre el régimen
de fujimori y el gobierno transición de
Valentín Paniagua Entonces tenemos una
una participación activa de la oea que
permitió una transición pacífica entre
un régimen autoritario a un régimen
democrático